hey there ladies and gents welcome to
the Shan method I'm your host Chris
waters something in for Shawn who is
down south doing video game things for
job joining these Benito Gonzalez when
you don't settle for Chris waters coming
in for Chris waters is Benito Gonzalez
and bonitos here to help me out because
today we're playing the sims 2 i've not
played the sims 2 very much at all but
you've got some serious Sims experience
I have some serious sims 1 experience
not so much for the sims 2 but I'm
guessing it's not to be pretty
comparable it's the sit we chose the
sims 2 because it's this year's the
10-year anniversary of this game coming
out and even though you know there I
haven't played a lot of the sims at all
but you got it it's undeniable the
influence that the sims have had on PC
gaming and the immense popularity that
those games still have today we're going
to try to recreate one of the great
dramas of our time the love triangle and
mushroom kingdom of course you know it
as Bowser kidnapping peach Mario
kidnapping her back but really you know
we're gonna recast this as a suburban
drama well they've settled down right
yeah they're much older now so this is
this is dad Bowser uh and this is his
daughter Wendy this is the Koopa family
and yeah congratulations okay yeah we
got to make them related child the
buzzers we make a child or just really
know that would be yeah I think though
unpleasant scenarios that nobody wants
to consider what do you like to listen
father daughter dance party Oh what is
that already happening alright if
they're getting grouchy with each other
yeah this is working out what's up Dina
Caliente oh hello except you know who I
really want Bowser to talk to his
princess peach is that peach oh that his
piece isn't it I think that's princess
peach daddy is having a guest over and
he is walking in on her in the bathroom
they are hanging out together in the
bathroom wow this is going better than I
ever could have hoped been you know okay
okay okay put something in front of the
bathroom door
let's see if we've managed to
successfully ensnare the princess how
unladylike she flushed after she was
done oh oh yeah yeah you're not going
anywhere asset impreza successfully cool
I mean it's hard now cuz they can't like
well you could change that table to him
once America's yeah real epic close and
personal just working her across the
table oh she's pissed cuz she can't move
alright meanwhile i think that's that's
pretty solid work so what what do we do
now so now let's see what Mario's state
of meanwhile tragedy strikes Mario
household piece is nowhere to be found
he just nowhere to be found she she's
just out for one of her walks she takes
him uh pretty often oh no wait she's
here damn it how is she here how did you
get it she's here and she's with the
baby baby alright so this is peach and
Baby Mario let's get a look at these two
each got out and they took out all the
fun stuff so you have to be super Trixie
about how you kill people that all right
here's peach and Baby Mario they are a
beautiful and happy family together this
thousand yard stare in her eyes is
because she wonders how life might have
been if she didn't get rescued all those
times so we need to get everyone in this
house before we try to set it on fire is
that what you're telling me yes and then
we need to open it up so that only some
of them escape and yet live to be
haunted we could also try tragedy can
also try to death pool how about like
some comforters
that seems safe relax everybody go have
a powwow in the kitchen have lunch we're
all the tubes TV dinner sure I do
declare I see may get a bunch of plants
in here stow oh yeah look at that it's a
nice little jungle picture of another
woman on your wall behind the fern I'm
fern above the stove so it's excellent
Mario your decoration is terrible oh
yeah she's hungry for chair all right
you need to make her chair struggle
turns four chance there we go oh my
picture he's pining over his he's pining
over it was this Pauline yeah why you
look at that picture paulita cash make
some mac and dang cheese I was
complaining about the beds she's got to
chop up the mac and cheese real quick
yeah make that Mac put it in a bowl
Mario what are you doing he's hungry too
he doesn't like nice and finally making
his TV dinner screw your mac and cheese
I want TV dinner yes use the oven now
run away to Little Rock to live nope
Brenda oh there you go there you go how
we go oh there's the way yeah this is
really odd there's no way out where's
the baby the baby's in the bathroom oh
no I can't build any furniture while
everything's on fire oh [ __ ] is it baby
gonna get orphaned we I yeah we got to
save the baby Mario run outside get out
that plate how do I save the baby baby
go to the door for all at the Tour baby
move baby save yourself baby iously Minh
can't you tell us a fire Mario's
freaking out he can't he's got to sit on
the couch Oh God which way there's no
way out it's horrible my Pauline picture
yeah oh it's all good on the bad the
baby's asleep wake your ass up baby oh
don't you it was a horrible fire all
right you should take a nap real quick
no Rose have a seat sit in the fire just
have a seat oh it's spreading no finer
spreading though we don't want to cancel
look baby got up baby got out baby where
are you baby baby you need to get you
need to go out the door save yourself
baby baby sleepy oh I'm so dad I can't
say my own life Mario continuing to just
stand and dance in front of the fires
hopelessly meanwhile this mac and cheese
is just going cold oh I guess I know now
yeah baby go outside they save yourself
I know you're not gonna be able to open
the door Oh babies off baby has carbon
monoxide poisoning and has passed out by
the bat he's farting constantly and he's
just ripping little baby ass over here
ok Meyers about to go down more it's
cutting is let's go down this is not
looking good for Mario oh gosh oh the
horror Mario pitch like he doesn't like
getting out watching as her longtime
Savior Mario burns in the flames well
you and buzzer will finally have is how
many burned items is Mario gonna oh
there he is turn those ashes Oh God
death has come death has come from Mario
and Peach is also on fire how do we get
peach not on fire we need to save ok
Italy extinguish there's no fire
extinguisher and what happens if you go
to the neighborhood now we might have an
orphan baby on our hands oh no we
definitely gonna have it no if it baby
let's see if death saves the baby is it
baby still alive the baby is fine are
you not gonna extinguish yourself I've
told you three times I'm not gonna tell
you again because she has to like get on
fire be on fire move in then
extinguishers oh all right let's just
let's just eliminate the being on fire
parts look use this rotten baby bottle
and just squeeze it all over yourself
you're all so smelly your smelly and I
oh there she died in into the ground
wire ok so we have we have a Norfolk
situation and there's Baby Mario passed
out in a cloud of his own stink death
will take care of him
this is about like a friend right now on
his cell phone death is like you get
Bowser you're not gonna believe this man
come see this bathroom Bowser I know you
remember you told me to call you if
anything happen to the Mario family well
I got some good news and some bad news
Mario is dead oh it's hey Benito it's
not a good idea baby yeah no that's
probably not got some good news bad news
Mario's dead but uh but slow speech
princess is also dead so so now you got
a little bittle just this baby so if you
want to like revenge raise the baby ah
that's cool you could do that is this
child services is it it is i think it is
child services is coming to take baby
mario away by just refuses right through
the wall where were you and it was on
fire count services lady this whose
child services lady in the Mushroom
Kingdom cannon oh that's a good question
she just came to abduct a baby phase
through a wall this is some sort of evil
sorceress who's the evil sorceress of
the Mushroom Kingdom oh there's the urn
I was that Marty alright as Mario ah
there are no actions available bonito
and isn't that one of the most touching
eulogies you've ever heard the Koopa
family is in mourning so let's go see
how Wendy Koopa and Bowser Koopa are
dealing with the recent tragedy and
they're dancing still dancing over at
the car literally dancing over the death
of Mariana bishop and the orphanage of
maybe Mario ah you can't make this stuff
up folks they're becoming a stronger
family
you